when porsche first unveiled the panamera
at the 2009 auto shanghai show
the public were astonished die hard
sports car fans rubbed their eyes when
they saw
a four-door luxury class car with a
front-mounted engine
what was the world coming to what was
porsche doing to its image
was the company jettisoning its
traditions and values
four years later porsche is bringing the
second generation of the panamera
onto the market a clear signal that the
boldness of the engineers and designers
has paid off
our test driver reinhold says this grand
turismo model
sold even better than expected porsche
was counting on selling 20
000 of them a year but has been shifting
30 000.
so unit sales since 2009 total more than
100
000 mostly in the united states in china
we'll show you how the panamera has
changed at the front
and back
and it's not just the appearance things
have improved under the hood too
downsizing is the key word when it comes
to what's new about the v6 engine
the result is up to 18 greater fuel
efficiency
than with the v8 in the older 4s model
with a displacement of three leaders
twin turbochargers produce 20 more
horsepower
and 20 newton meters more torque than
the preceding v8
porsche is unleashing 10 different
versions of the panamera simultaneously
all new are two long executive versions
that provide more comfort and legroom in
the back
we checked out the panamera 4s executive
with the new v6 engine
top speed is 286 kilometers an hour
and it accelerates from zero to 100 in
just five seconds
fuel consumption is officially nine
liters per 100 kilometers
the stretch version is 5.17 meters long
and weighs
exactly two tons only a few tweaks have
changed the front
like on the hood's power dome and on the
headlights
the panamera executive is shorter than
its direct competitors
10 centimeters shorter than the long
version of the audi a8 and 5 centimeters
shorter than a regular bmw
7 series
the long panamera's wheelbase has
increased by
15 centimeters and the back doors are
longer too which makes getting into the
back seats a lot more comfortable
the new panamera hasn't changed much
upfront says reinhold
the headlights are rounder the air
intakes bigger
the power dome on the hood and the
rocker panels on the sides are more
striking
but criticism of the old version focused
on the rear so now the back window
is wider and flatter the rear lights are
new
and in particular the license plate has
been lowered
giving the panamera a better appearance
from behind
here's what the rear looks like as a
whole compared with its predecessor
shown here in black on the left
the button to open the rear hatch is
hidden under the rear windshield wiper
the trunk holds between 445 and 1265
liters of luggage
15 centimeters the panamera executive
has grown by 15 centimeters resulting in
more legroom and space to work in for
rear passengers
if the front passenger seat is vacant
you can move that seat forward from
behind
the executive versions cater to buyers
of chauffeured limousines
but these vehicles drivers are in an
enviable position too
the instruments in front of them and to
the sides are within
easy reach convenient are also the front
and rear parking assists
they provide a nice overview in
otherwise unclear parking situations
power controls enable passengers to
individually adjust the separate back
seats for comfort
the panamera 4s executive costs in
excess of 132
000 euros in germany that makes the
stretch version 25 and a half thousand
more expensive
than a normal 4s porsches come at a
price
including gran turismo versions the long
models from the competition the audi
a8l and the bmw 7 series are available
for 50 or 60 000 euros less
you